america goes woke and abandons all
common sense tucker carlson highlights
how one country's fighting back against
far left policies it's featured in a
brand new episode of his fox nation
original series that drops tomorrow
hungary versus george soros the fight
for civilization here's a preview
in the united states he has installed
radical prosecutors who refused to
enforce the law
in europe he tried to topple
democratically elected governments in
georgia romania and ukraine
he spent vast sums of money encouraging
europe and the united states to accept
millions of foreign migrants
despite soros's best efforts one
unlikely country is fighting back that
country is hungary the very place george
soros was born
tucker joins us now all right tucker so
what was the game plan for the hungarian
leader to fight back against soros well
nothing complicated that was the real
lesson they didn't really do anything
that you know you and i couldn't come up
with over a cup of coffee in about 20
minutes they just built a fence and put
a couple guys there with a dog and that
was it and they were but they were
serious about it you know this is our
country 10 million people
landlocked been invaded a lot over the
last thousand years and we want to
control who comes in we're not against
immigrants we just want to know who they
are and if you come here without
permission
here's their whole immigration strategy
i watched it firsthand they take the
guys they take their picture they
interview them and then like 15 minutes
later they lead them outside the fence
and let them back into slovakia and
that's the whole thing and it works and
that's kind of what they do in
everything in hungary it's not a radical
country it's not a theocracy
it's a very sort of simple sweet country
with some problems like every country
but they just kind of try to make it
better that's all they do and the beauty
of going there is you realize it's not
hard you just have to sort of want to
make your country better a little bit
again nothing radical and you can have a
much better country oh all right we'll
take it around the table that sounds
like a nice idea judge jeanine hey
tucker what are they doing about soros
so they tried to remove him or prosecute
him or do any of the things that he
would do to us if he could so there i
did no no of course not nothing like
that whatsoever soros was born in
hungary raised there he's lived in
london in the u.s and dealt with other
countries too in the ensuing 65 years
but he spends a lot of money on what are
known as ngos non-governmental
organizations basically massive lobby
groups international accountable to no
one that try to change the internal
politics of hungary and the hungarian
government has basically just said out
loud we don't like this this is
subverting democracy these are
non-citizens or not hungarians trying to
influence our internal political program
again that's what we would call in this
country an attack on democracy the bide
administration supports it they attack
the hungarian government because they
don't want foreigners trying to decide
who gets elected there the whole thing
is like you realize democracy
is the opposite of what they say it is
their view of democracy is one
billionaire gets to run your country
that's not my view of democracy i don't
think it's most people's geraldo rivera
uh erica hi tucker erica and i visited
budapest uh the summer of 2020 they were
looking forward to the elections coming
up in april uh victor obama the
president uh very controversial there
they he's thought of as authoritarian uh
you know also on the ballot is the fact
that in hungary they're not allowed to
teach lgbtq
uh you know facts of life until a kid is
18 or over uh do you want america to be
more like hungry is that why you did
this well i don't know if they'd say if
i'd say it's authoritarian i mean they
didn't lock up hundreds of people
without trial and solitary confinement
for staging a political protest or
trespassing we did do that and are still
doing it nothing like that as far as i
know is happening in hungary there are
no political prisoners orban could lose
by the way in the elections in april so
it's it's hardly this monolithic
one-party state it's not like one party
controls all the levers of government
like is the case in this country i mean
look i'm an american i love america i
will always defend america but the idea
that hungary is less a democracy than
the us or than ukraine i mean it's just
a lie anyone who says that is either
lying or doesn't know anything
gg so i'm going to ask a super naive
question because that's what i do um i'm
like everybody here infuriated by the
funding of the these progressive das by
the source i guess it's open society or
whatever it's called so i go and i look
i look him up and i go okay he actually
sounds like in the 80s i remember in the
80s how beloved he was because he helped
with the fall of the ussr if my memory
is correct and i remember reading about
it national review and the american
spectator and i'm reading about his past
and i go you know his dad was in siberia
in a siberian prison he escaped from
nazi germany he helped with the fall of
ussr
does is he aware
that his money is being used to destroy
america is this is something where he's
not paying attention to it because he's
in his 90s i know i told you it was a
naive question well i wouldn't just say
america i would say the west western
civilization is his target and i know a
lot of people who know soros personally
and some people have done business with
him every single person knows him says
this is one of the smartest most
interesting people in the world and i
believe that and i'm impressed by it but
his program for the past 15 years at
least has been to make the societies he
focuses on more dangerous
dirtier less democratic more
disorganized more at war with themselves
less cohesive in other words it's a
program of destruction aimed at the west
now i don't you know i don't know what
his motive is i'm certainly not going to
guess people are complicated he clearly
is but that's what that program is so
let's not pretend it's a political
program it's not increasing the number
of murders in a country what is that
it's an attack on the country and that's
what he's doing dana is that the well
i'm curious does he have that kind of
effect or does he put that kind of money
into hungary as well
well he certainly tried um yeah he's put
a lot of money into hungary um
through these non-governmental
organizations and let's just let's just
be clear if george soros walked around
budapest which he does i think every
year he would be better treated than i
am in midtown manhattan so this is a
country that tolerates dissent in a way
that the united states doesn't i mean i
talked to people who were opposed to the
orban government you know they were
eating outside in restaurants again
there are people sitting on your set
right now who can't do that in new york
because someone spit on them so like
the caricature it's not my job to defend
hungary only to learn from it as an
american and try and hold up the lessons
for us to emulate but the idea that this
is a police state or some theocracy or
even like a right-wing country that's
like ridiculous ask anybody who spends
you know a lot of the movie business is
now working out of budapest because of
tax breaks ask any of those guys you
know also they bring really great dogs
yeah there you go
the national dog yeah heard of them
our very own person very own person
all right tucker thank you so much thank
you very own tucker thanks guys hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else